the dream is tough to realize you see
bits of it and then you see darkness
come he will often use the analogy would
say you're trying you go on the mountain
you go in this thing you see the cities
light keep wanting gets dark
but don't stop because you keep going
become a higher don't stop so the fact
that we can now vote as a part of the
dream we're building coalitions part of
the dream 55 african-american in the
Congress is a dream a woman in the
Senate a dream having American pressure
on the dream Mandela been fruit and gel
in South Africa so once he's evidence of
the dream but also the dreamers on the
attack so there you see the attempt to
suppress to vote rather than has to vote
the dreamers on the attack you see the
temperature on the man fool health
insurance it's supposed to maintain it
the dream is the Brazilian the dream
will prevail because we will not give up
a formal education affordable health
care reconciliation over polarization we
will prevail
[Music]